[موسيقى]
قد توصلنا الى اتفاق مع سلاح الجو في جنوب
افريقيا الذي يقوم بموجب الاتفاق بتجربه
وتقييم الطائره المسيره وفقا لمتطلباته
بغيت تزويدنا بملاحظاته حولها ويتضمن
الاتفاق ايضا بعد حالات الاستخدام
العملياتي وصولا الى نشر هذه الطائره
المسيره بشكل كامل ويعود السبب في ذلك الى
اننا نفضل العمل مع مستخدمي منتجاتنا
لنفهم احتياجاتهم على الرغم من توفر فريق
فني مقتدر لدى الشركه
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للنشاطنا على الصعيد العالمي
لدينا وجود كبير في اكثر من 70 بلدا يتم
تسويق منتجاتنا
كفاءه قسم التسويق في الشركه ولقد اجرينا
قدرا كبيرا من النقاشات رفيعه المستوى لا
سيما بشان الطائره المسيره
380 ونحن متفائلون جدا حيال المبيعات
المستقبليه لهذه المسيره
[موسيقى]